COMMITTEE ON RULES TO ORDER HI
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
GONNA MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
OUR PROCESSES- THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH OUR PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
THAT MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME SOMEBODY COVERED THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN HERE
NOW. AND A COUPLE MORE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
WILL OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT
TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK. YOU HAVE TO MUTE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU SO
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OUR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
AND WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IT IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. BUT AGAIN
AGAIN AGAIN LET ME SAY BE
PATIENT- SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD AND WE WILL GET THROUGH
IT. ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER I WOULD ASK THAT ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES A LIGHT. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY ANNA AS WE
BEGIN THE AGENDA TODAY WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND AS A
REMINDER TO MEMBERS- YOU'LL
NEED TO TURN YOUR MIKE ON-
BEFORE- YOU SPEAK FOR ROLL CALL
AND ANSWERING YOUR COMMENTS.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROW YOUR ROLE
HERE KAMLAGER HERE MOTHER HERE
GLARED HERE THEY'RE HERE EIGHT
YEARS. HERE ASKING HERE AND
HERE OKAY- BEFORE- WE GO TO OUR
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR I
DON'T WANT TO DISPENSE WITH
SOME ITEMS AND- SINCE THERE'S A
LONG LIST I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
VOTES AND I'M GOING TO READ
THEM OFF BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO SPLIT SOME VOTES. SO
FOR ITEM TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THAT WOULD INCLUDE THESE
ITEMS SO IT WOULD BE TO SEE TWO
D. TWO E. THEY WERE GONNA JUMP
DOWN TO TWO H. I J. K. M. AND
THAT WOULD BE THE FIRST MOTION
LET ME KNOW IF YOU NEED ME TO
REPEAT THAT I WOULD SO MOVE
OKAY I THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL ROVE
HI FOUR FIVE KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER I LAYERED HI THERE I
FAITH ALL RIGHT BATES AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU THOSE ARE OUT
FIVE TWO ZERO NOW THE NEXT
MOTION. WOULD BE ON OUR ITEMS
TO. ALSO BUT IT WOULD INCLUDE
TWO F. G. L. IN- O. AND P. I
WOULD MOVE THAT THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- EVERYBODY'S
WITH US MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL
THE ROLL ROAD ROVE NOT VOTING
KAMLAGER HI LONGER I LAYERED HI
THERE I FAITH NOT VOTING IT'S
NOT VOTING ATKINS HI FIVE THREE
TWO ZERO OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
OUT THREE TO ZERO AND- WERE I
WOULD NEXT- ENTERTAIN AND ITEM
IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH IT ON-
THREE BILL REFERRALS AND FOR
SELECT COMMITTEE REQUEST IF
PEOPLE ARE OKAY TAKE BOTH OF
THOSE AT THE SAME TIME I WOULD
MOVE THEM TOGETHER THREE AND
FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR LAYER
MAN'S SECRETARY HELLO HI I
KAMLAGER HI ROBERT I LAYERED HI
THERE I STATE ALL RIGHT I AT
FIVE FIVE FIVE ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
IS OUT SO WE WILL NOW TURN THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR IN THAT WOULD BE FOR
ITEM ONE A. N. B. WE WILL TAKE
THOSE UP TOGETHER AND IT IS TWO
APPOINTMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND THEY ARE AND
I'M GONNA HOPE I GET NAMES
CORRECTLY AND YOU WILL CORRECT
ME IF I AM WRONG PLEASE- MISTER
JEFFREY MACABRE AT THANK YOU AS
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS.
N. MISS JENNIFER BARRETTO-
UNDER SECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATION. I'M GOING TO
SAY WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS
WE GET UNDER WAY- I WOULD LIKE
TO. DO IT IN ORDER OF THE FILE
BEGINNING WITH MISTER MCCUMBER
AND DIDN'T MISS BARRETTO. AT
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR INTRODUCTIONS
ARE OPENING COMMENTS- FEEL FREE
TO A KNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE A SPECIALLY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN AFTER BOTH OF YOU HAVE
HAD A CHANCE TO DO THAT WILL GO
RIGHT TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. SO I
THINK WITH THAT. MR CALMER GO
AHEAD IN- INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND WE'LL GO FROM THERE WELCOME
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE AND TAKE MY FAMILY AS
WELL AS BY SUITS YOUR FAMILY
WHO ARE SUPPORTING ME HERE
TODAY M. I. A. CAREER AS INTO
STAR AS A STUDENT ASSISTANT
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. I FELT
VERY IS POSITIONED IN THAT
APARTMENT RANGING FROM CRISIS
OFFICER TO THE DIRECTOR OF
CORRECTIONS SERVICES. AT THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHICH ALLOWED ME
TO EXPERIENCE THE CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM THROUGH THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE PHONE RECEIVER IN CHARGE
OF HEALTH CARE SHORTLY
AFTERWARD I WAS ASKED TO
SERVICE THE UNDERSECRETARY OF
THE MINISTRATION. BY MINIMUM
PRIORITY TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
APARTMENT WAS ABLE TO BEAT. ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS TO
ESTABLISH TECHNOLOGICAL
MANAGEMENT TOOLS TO ALLOW FOR A
REAL TIME DATA DRIVEN DECISION
MAKING MODEL. AND TO ENHANCE
STAFF TRAINING FOR NEW PEACE
OFFICERS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
THESE PIECES ARE ESSENTIAL IF
WE ARE TO SUCCEED IN OUR
MISSION I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
STRONGLY IN THIS MISSION I HAVE
SEEN A WORK THIS PAST YEAR AND
A HALF OVER WE HAVE FACED ONE
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES TO OUR MISSION I
HAVE EXPRESSED MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS WITH THE DEPARTMENT THE
IMPACT TO THE POPULATION LIVING
IN OUR FACILITIES THE STAFF TO
WORK THERE CANNOT BE OVERSTATED
THE COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMIC
UPENDED ALL NORMAL DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS SEEMINGLY OVERNIGHT.
EMPIRE REYES HAD TO BE SHIFTED
TO FOCUS ON OUTBREAK MEDICATION
DURING THIS TRYING YEAR I WAS
ASKED TO SERVICE THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS AT
THAT TIME THE DEPARTMENT
OVERALL ITS OPERATIONS TO
CONFRONT THE DIFFICULTIES THE
COMPANY IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE MANY
NUMEROUS DEFINITIONS INCLUDING
PURSUING A PUBLIC HEALTH FOCUS
CORRECTIONAL CULTURE CHANGE
PROGRAM SIMILAR TO THE NORWAY
MODEL. EXPANDING THE
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY THE PERSONAL
TABLETS AND LAPTOPS. I ONLY AND
NOW EXPANDING THE USE OF BODY
WORN CAMERAS IN CORRECTIONAL
SETTINGS. ESTABLISHING A
GREATEST SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT PROGRAM TO MEDICALLY
AT THERAPEUTICALLY ADDRESS
SUBSTANCE DEPENDENCY INTERESTED
TUITIONS RENDERING TE FIRST
CLASS OF FIREFIGHTERS FROM THE
DETERRENT TRAINING CENTER AND
IMPLEMENTING THE AREN'T JUST
CHARGE PROCESS FOR PAROLEES
BASED ON BEHAVIOR AND MERIT.
AND NOT TO LEAVE OUT OF
TRANSITIONING THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE TO THE
COUNTIES ALTHOUGH NOT WITHOUT
ITS CHALLENGES CESAR CONTINUES
TO EVOLVE FOR THE BETTER I FEEL
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE A- A BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY PART OF
THIS TRANSFORMATION. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
POINTING ME TO THIS CRITICAL
ROLE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE SENATE TODAY FOR CONCERNING
MY APPOINTMENT. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO AFFECT
CHANGE IN THIS NEW ROLE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR THOSE COMMENTS- MISSOURI GO
AHEAD BREDOW GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JENNIFER BARRETTO AND I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY FAMILY MY HUSBAND JEFF AND
OUR TWO SONS JEFFREY AND CHASE
RATHER UNWAVERING SUPPORT AND
SACRIFICE I MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE
MY CD'S OUR FAMILY WHO HAVE
ASSISTED AND ENCOURAGED ME
ALONG MY CAREER JOURNEY. MIGHT
HAVE TO YOU TODAY IS AN
UNCOMMON ONE HAVING STARTED
CDCR AS ENTRY CLERICAL SUPPORT
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHILE
PUTTING MYSELF THROUGH COLLEGE
THROUGH DETERMINATION AND
PERSISTENCE I WAS ABLE TO WORK
MY WAY UP THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE RANKS ULTIMATELY
TRANSITION TO PEACE OFFICER
CLASSIFICATIONS. INCLUDING
CORRECTIONAL BUSINESS MANAGER
CORRECTIONAL MINISTRY- CHIEF
DEPUTY WARDEN AND WARDEN EACH
POSITION REPRESENTED A NEW
CHALLENGE AND AN ABILITY TO
HAVE A BIGGER IMPACT. I ALSO
WORKED AS THE DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE POLICY AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER PROVIDING ME WITH NEW
PERSPECTIVE OVER PRISON HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. THE JOURNEY WAS
NOT EASY I HAD TO WORK VERY
HARD TO EARN RESPECT AND
ACCEPTANCE AND MANY OF THE
POSITIONS THAT I ATTAINED
DESPITE THE CHALLENGES I HAVE
FOUND THE JOURNEY TO BE DEEPLY
REWARDING AS UNDER FOR
ADMINISTRATION AREAS I OVERSEE
PROVIDE CRITICAL SUPPORT TO OUR
MISSION OF SAVORY ABILITY SHIN
OF INCARCERATED PERSONS. THESE
INCLUDE FACILITY MAINTENANCE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY STAFF TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT THIS CALL
MANAGEMENT TO NAME A FEW I HOPE
TO MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOLLARS INVESTED IN OUR STAFF
AND OUR TECHNOLOGY AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE I AM COMMITTED
TO IMPROVING THE STAFF
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATION REVIEW
PROCESS AND RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRANSPARENCY AND
COLLABORATION AND GAINING
TRUST. I RECOGNIZE THE CODE
PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED ANXIETY AND
CONCERN FOR OUR STAFF AND THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION I
COMMITTED TO KEEPING BOTH SAFE
ENSURING THE AVAILABILITY OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND IN HERE IT'S TO PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES. I BELIEVE
INVESTING IN STAFF THROUGH
EMPLOYEE WELLNESS UPWARD
MOBILITY SUCCESSION MANAGEMENT
MENTORSHIP QUALITY TRAINING AND
TECHNOLOGY IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR
SUCCESS AND TO TRULY BE
SUCCESSFUL IT REQUIRES
RECRUITING EQUIPPING AND RETAIN
IT AT AND IT RETAINING A
TALENTED WORKFORCE WITH FOCUSED
ATTENTION ON EQUITY EQUAL.
OPPORTUNITY. AND DIVERSITY TO
WHICH I'M COMMITTED BURKE HAS
TO THE STAFF REALITY BASED
TRAINING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
ACTIVE BYSTANDER CHIP FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL BETTER EQUIP
OUR STAFF SUPPORT THEIR
WELLNESS AND BENEFIT CONTINUED
CULTURE TRANSFORMATION WHEN I
STARTED AT CDC ARE WE WERE
FACING CONTINUOUS BUDGET
REDUCTIONS SEVERE OVERCROWDING
DIMINISHED PRISON PROGRAMS
STAFF TRAINING WAS ALL BUT
ELIMINATED AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS NEGLECTED
OUR TECHNOLOGY WAS ALSO FALLING
BEHIND. I AM PROUD OF WHAT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED WITH REDUCE
POPULATION EXPANDED PRISON
PROGRAMS INVESTMENTS IN OUR
STAFF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY AND I RECOGNIZE THE
REMAINS MUCH TO DO. I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
THIS APPOINTMENT AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE TODAY FOR
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I'M GOING TO GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS AND I ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF YOU- INTENDED DIRECT
QUESTIONS ARE INDIVIDUALLY TO-
TO DO SO AND IF YOU WANT BOTH
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE SAME
TIME. MAKE THAT CLEAR AS WELL
SO SENATOR LAYERED I WILL GO
AHEAD START WITH YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. IN
ENJOYED MEETING WITH YOU BOTH
IT WAS REALLY HELPFUL AND I
THINK A LOT OF MY QUESTIONS
WERE. ANSWERED IN THE MEETING
BUT I THINK I'D LIKE TO ASK. A
COUPLE OF THEM TO PUT THEM JUST
TALK ABOUT THEM IN PUBLIC END.
OF FOR MS BARRETTO I WOULD
START WITH YOU AND YOU SAID IN
YOUR PENING STATEMENT. THAT
YOU WERE THERE DURING MAJOR
CUTS IN DIFFICULT TIMES AND WE
TALKED ABOUT A TIME THAT I WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE BUDGET ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS AGO WERE THE
PRISON SYSTEM DIDN'T EVEN SET
UP THE BOOKS OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED UNTIL. SIX
MONTHS INTO THE FISCAL YEAR AND
IT CAUSED A PROBLEM AND- YOU
GAVE ME A GREAT ANSWER ABOUT
WHY THAT IS JUST NOT GONNA
HAPPEN NOW. AND SO WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT CURRENT SYSTEMS AND
WHAT YOU HAVE ON PUT IN. IN
PLACE TO MANAGE THE BUDGET
CERTAINLY THANK YOU SENATOR
WELL I I'M FAMILIAR WITH THAT
THE BUDGET. PROCESS AND WHAT IT
LOOKED TO BE IN OUR HISTORY AND
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. AND I AM
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT WE HAVE
NEED CONSIDERABLE STRIDES FROM
THOSE TIMES LONG AGO WITH A
GREAT DEAL OF TECHNOLOGY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
WE HAVE AN AUTOMATED
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM FOR OUR
BUDGET OUT FUNCTIONS. FOR ALL
OUR FISCAL FORECASTING
PROJECTING- ACCOUNTABILITY OF
EXPENDITURES. IT IS COORDINATED
FROM OUR HEADQUARTERS
OPERATION. EACH INSTITUTION HAS
A TRAINED BUDGET ANALYST THEY
HAVE A BUSINESS MANAGER. AND
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING THOSE PROJECTS BUT IT
COMES WITH A GREAT DEAL OF
OVERSIGHT AND REAL TIME
AVAILABLE DATA TO US ON
EXPENDITURES. WE ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CONTROL SPENDING WE
HAVE WHAT IS CALLED
AVAILABILITY CONTROL IN OUR
ELECTRONIC SYSTEMS. WHERE WE
CAN TURN OFF AND ON LINE ITEMS
ESSENTIALLY- AS WE WATCH-
EXPENDITURES. WE ALSO HAVE
ROUTINE MEETINGS- WE NEED
MONTHLY LOOKING AT THOSE
EXPENDITURES LOOKING AT
ANYTHING THAT'S OF CONCERN. AND
WE HAVE- ANNUAL FISCAL REVIEWS
AS WELL. SO THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
I'VE BEEN AFFORDED. TO US BY
USING TECHNOLOGY GREAT THANK
YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE. OF
THAT ANSWER AND- AND HEARING
FROM IT FROM YOU DIRECTLY IN
THE HEARING. AND THEN I HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
MCCUMBER TO FOLLOW UP THE FIRST
IS NOW YOU'RE TAKING OVER
OPERATIONS AND BEFORE YOU THE
WE'RE SORT OF FORMALLY ALL THE
WAY IN THIS POSITION THERE WERE
MAJOR ISSUES WITH REGARD TO
CODE AND THE PRISON SYSTEM
COULD YOU SPEAK TO SORT OF HOW
YOU HAVE- WORKED WITH THOSE
BECAUSE YOU WALK IN AND THEY
HAD ALREADY HAPPENED TO SOME OF
THE MAJOR ONES HOW'VE YOU
ADDRESS THAT HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT THE SYSTEM IS ADDRESSING
IT GOING FOR. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION EARLY ON AND WE DID
NOT KNOW AS MUCH ABOUT THE
VIRUSES WE DO NOW WE ARE
FORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE ABOUT
ROBUST TESTING PROTOCOLS WE
HAVE ROBUST- PP EQUIPMENT-
RANGING FROM BASS TO TWO OTHER
ITEMS WE'VE ALSO BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE WITH VACCINATIONS
WHAT ABOUT SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT- OVER A CURSORY
POPULATION THAT HAS RECEIVED A
CALL BACK SOON ABOUT FIFTY
THREE. PERCENT OF OUR STAFF
WE'RE WE'RE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION RIGHT NOW TO DEAL WITH
COLDER THAN WE WERE ORIGINALLY
WE'VE ALSO OF COURSE REDUCED
OUR POPULATIONS SIGNIFICANTLY
TODAY WE STAND JUST OVER NINETY
NINE THOUSAND AND BATES- WORD
DOWN- WELL OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND- INCARCERATED FOLKS
FROM WHERE WE STARTED SO I
THINK THOSE THOSE ITEMS
SPECIFICALLY HELPED US WE'VE
ALSO. LEARNED WHICH AREAS OF
THE INSTITUTIONS ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE- FOR- COOLEY
TRANSMISSION WE'VE DONE OUR
BEST TO MOVE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE A HIGHER RISK FOR COLD
AND- JUST SAFER HOUSING WAS
TYPICALLY MEANS BEHIND US ALL
IT'S ALL FRONTS I THINK WE MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT THAT.
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM- EXTERNAL
SUCH AS- DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH THE LEGISLATURE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OTHERS-
IN GETTING US TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AND I HAVE TO ASK AN EDGY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
SAID THAT 53% OF THE STAFF HAD
BEEN VACCINATED. WHY ISN'T THAT
NUMBER HIGHER WELL WE SAW
ENCOURAGE OUR STAFF TO GET
BACKSTAGE I MYSELF GOT BACKS IT
EARLY IN THE PROCESS TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR THAT.
AS DO OUR ARE PARTNERS IN
HEALTH CARE- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS NOW OF IMPLEMENTING THE
LATEST- DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDER- WHICH DOES
REQUIRE VACCINATIONS FOR OUR
STAFF TO THEIR WORK IN HEALTH
CARE SETTINGS. ARE INVOLVED AND
I TRANSPORTATION OF THE
INCARCERATED POPULATIONS THE
THINGS LIKE MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS. AS WELL AS TO OUR
FACILITIES THAT HAVE A PRIMARY
HEALTH CARE MISSION NOT BEING
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY. THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL FACILITY AND THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WITHIN
OUR CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY IN CHOWCHILLA. SO WE
ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND THOSE
NUMBERS OF UNVACCINATED STAFF.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE CLOSELY.
FOLLOWING- THE ANY ANY
ADDITIONAL PH KIND SUCCUMBS TO-
THE FIZER MAXION OTHER VACCINES
ARE GAINING FDA APPROVAL OKAY
THANK YOU BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT NUMBER
GO UP AND THEN THE OTHER A
QUESTION LAST QUESTION I HAD-
HAS TO DO WITH. OF S. B. R. ONE
THIRTY TWO AND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS THAT SELF IDENTIFY
AS- TRANS GENDER NON BINARY OR
INTERSEX AND HE YOU KNOW IN IN
THE PROCESS BETWEEN YOU AND
YOUR STAFF ARE WE WENT BACK AND
FORTH THERE WERE. ABOUT EIGHT
ASSERTIONS MADE THAT WERE NOT
TRUE AND I DON'T WANT TO GIVE
LIFE TO ALL THE SOLUTIONS BY
REPEATING THEM BUT I THINK THAT
IT WOULD BE GOOD IF MAYBE YOU
GAVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THIS SAID AND WHERE
IT STANDS IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT
YES WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING SP ONE THIRTY TWO.
WE HAVE FACED. CRITICISMS FROM
ADVOCATES ON ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE ISSUE SOME FILL THAT WE
ARE- MOVING TOO SLOWLY AND
OTHERS FEEL THAT WE'RE MOVING
TOO FAST- WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT
HAVE ELECTED. TO SLOW DOWN A
LITTLE BIT- AN ARTICLE DAIS OF
SP ONE THIRTY TWO WERE WERE
LOOKING TO CONTRACT WITH-
NATIONWIDE EXPERTS ON THIS
ISSUE TO HELP US NAVIGATE A
COMPLEX ISSUE. I WAS VERYFORTUNATE THIS PAST MONDAY- TO
SPEND SOME TIME AT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY
WHERE. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT DOWN THE TRANSGENDER WOMEN
TRANSGENDER MEN- AS WELL AS A
CISGENDER POPULATION- TO TALK
ABOUT THEIR- CONCERNED WITH SP
ONE THIRTY TWO. AND IT WAS
REALLY- IT WAS REALLY GOOD FOR
ME TO HEAR IT A STRAIGHT FROM
THE FROM THE FOLKS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY LIVING THIS- DAY
TODAY- AND SO AS A DEPARTMENT
AS I SAID WE'RE SLOWING DOWN
LITTLE BIT WE WANT TO MAKE WE
GET THIS RIGHT WE WANTED SURE
WERE PROVIDING SAFE HOUSING FOR
A POPULATION- IT WE GET WE GET
THIS RIGHT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT MMHM IN A
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO COME BACK
TO IT IF THERE'S AN ANIMATED
DISCUSSION BUT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THAT COMPLETES MY QUEST
THE SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR. WELL LET ME I
CONGRATULATE YOU MR O'CONNOR
AND MR AT SHOW- FOR. YOUR
NOMINATION OUGHT TO THESE VERY
IMPORTANT POSITIONS AND I WAS
NOTICING FROM YOUR- BIOS THAT
FOR COMBINED SERVICE YOU
PROVIDED TO. THE- DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
I THINK IF I ADDED IT UP RIGHT
CRISIS ABOUT FIFTY TWO YEARS IN
IN PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT. YET SHOULD BE
REWARDING A FINE MESS WHEN
PEOPLE ENTER THE PRISON SYSTEM
AND YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SOMETHING SO THAT THEY CAN
RE ENTER SOCIETY SO I THANK YOU
FOR THAT SERVICE AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO IT HE WOULD HAVE
SERVED OUT LONG IF YOU DON'T
HAVE. A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT
AND PASSION ABOUT IT THERE HAVE
BEEN PROBLEMS ON MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE ON MENTIONED THOSE
REGARDING THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE ON COVERED IN NEWS
ARTICLES ACTUALLY REGARDING ON
THE TRANSFER OF MANSFIELD
FEMALE INSTITUTIONS AND HOW
THAT IS GOING AND I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION A MAYBE ON MY
ONLY QUESTION ON THE F. WOULD
BE ON COULD WE AVOID SOME OF
THE OF INFORMATION WHETHER IT'S
ACCURATE OR INACCURATE BY
ENSURING THAT THOSE WHO ARE
TRANSFERRED OF FOR THE NEED- TO
BE HAVE THE TRANSFORMATION
SURGERY BE HELD IN A SEPARATE
AREA SO WE DIDN'T HAVE CONCERNS
THAT ARE ACTUAL OR PERHAPS- NOT
SO ACCURATE THAT FOMENTED BY
FROM WOULD APPEAR TO BE FROM
PREVIOUS- YOU KNOW INFORMATION
PERHAPS FROM STAFF- TO HEIGHTEN
FEAR ABOUT IT AMONGST THE WOMEN
POPULATION. SO MY QUESTION IS
LAW IT SHOULD BE B. AND
SEPARATE. OF FACILITY UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH THE
TRANSFORMATION SURGERY OTHER
ANY CONSIDERATION TO DO THAT
ALL TAKE UP FOR A SHOT AT THIS
ONE. SO WE EVALUATE HOUSING FOR
ALL OF OUR INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND EVENTUALLY AND
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS ARE MOST
APPROPRIATE- FOR SOME HOUSING
AND THAT COULD BE SINGLE SO
WE'RE DOUBLE SALT- OTHER OF OUR
FACILITIES- IT SUCH A CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY HAS
ROOMS THAT HOLD- YOU KNOW FOUR
TO SIX INDIVIDUALS AND WE WERE
VIEW OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS BASED ON
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CASE FACTORS
IN THE CASE FACTORS OF THOSE-
INDIVIDUALS THEY MIGHT BE
LIVING WEST SO WE DO A CASE BY
CASE ANALYSIS ON THAT- AND
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING AT.
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE THAT
PROCESS CAN YOU AT THIS POINT
IN TIME IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS I WOULD SAY
THAT WOULD BE ACT YES BECAUSE I
THINK FOR THOSE OF US ON THE
OUTSIDE LOOKING OUT WHAT SEEM
TO BE A VERY GOOD. PROGRAM
GIVEN UPDATE THE ISSUES THAT
HAD ARISEN AMOUNT OF SEVERAL OF
THE INMATES I THINK THEY'RE
WHAT TO ENTER SIXTY ONE WHO
REQUESTED. OF THEM WHO ARE
TRANSGENDER AND REQUESTED TO BE
MOVED AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT.
SORT OF PROBLEMS THEY WERE YOU
KNOW FACING BEING- CONSIDERING
THEMSELVES FEMALE AND BEING IN
THE MAIL INSTITUTIONS THAT
WOULD BE N FARRAND OF- AS
WE'RE HEARING REPORTS WITH-
MAN. COMING INTO THE WOMEN WHO
ARE STILL AT ATOMICALLY MAN
COMING INTO THE WOMEN'S
INSTITUTIONS AND BEING IN THE
YOU KNOW THE SHOWERS TOGETHER
AND ALL OF THAT SO- IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT I THINK GOING FORWARD
THAT THAT IS ADDRESSED YEAH AND
IT'S ADDRESSED VERY UP FRONT.
SO THAT WE AREN'T IN THE
POSITION OF LEGISLATORS TO
CONTINUALLY DEAL WITH WHAT MAY
BE ACCURATE OR INACCURATE
INFORMATION- BECAUSE I THINK
OUR JOB ESPECIALLY WITH OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IS TO ENSURE THAT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE THAT WE ARE ALL VERY
STRONGLY BEHIND. IS WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING IN OUR
FACILITIES BOB YEAH I DID THAT
IS THE UP COMMITMENT I THINK
MOST OF US WHO ARE HERE AND
HAVE BEEN HERE. COMING UP TO
THIS POINT IN TIME WANT THAT TO
BE. THE MESSAGE- AMMUNITION IN
THE MESSAGE ANOTHER. QUESTION I
HAVE ON IT NO DETAILS ON THE
CLOSE ABOUT IN OUR THAT DURING
TIME YOU ARE NOT TO. IN PERSON
PROGRAMS GOING ON- AND THAT WAS
QUESTION NOW IS WHETHER WE'RE
REALLY GETTING TO THE HEART OF
THE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
THAT INDIVIDUAL. WHO ARE
INCARCERATED REALLY NEED SO
THEY CAN GET ON THE PATH OF
RECOVERY AND GET BACK. INTO
SOCIETY AND OPPORTUNITIES THERE
TO YOU KNOW HAVE A REAL LIFE.
SO HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
REINSTITUTE WITH THE
VACCINATION PROGRAM REINSTITUTE
THE REHABILITATION ALL PROGRAMS
IN PERSON TO PERSON AND BEING
ABLE TO A FAST. ANALYZE STUFF
WHAT PARTICULAR AREA A
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WOULD BE
BEST SUITED FOR I'M THINKING
ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE IN BECAUSE
OF SUBSTANCE COULD. I USE ABUSE
AND WHAT PATH THAT PUT THEM ON
UNFORTUNATELY OTHERS WHO MAY
HAVE. YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
LEVEL FROM ABUSE IN THEIR LIFE
AT EVERY LEVEL ON WHO. YOU
DON'T NEED TO HAVE A NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT. SO I EIGHT ONE
THAT PROVIDES THE EDUCATION
THAT THEY DIDN'T RECEIVE SHOULD
HAVE RECEIVED BUT CERTAINLY WE
FAILED THEM ON THAT FRONT ALSO.
WILLGIVE ME SOME THOUGHTS
ABOUT WHETHER YOU'RE ABLE TO
BEGIN THAT PROGRAM AND WHAT IS
GOING ON- IN TERMS OF.
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN HAVE
RESULTS FROM AND. WE HAVE
MEASURABLE RESULTS FROM MY
QUESTION YES WE ARE- FALL IN
WHAT WE CALL A ROADMAP TO
REALTY WHICH IS A PHASED
APPROACH AS- COLLUDED- CASES
INVOLVING ARE INCARCERATED
POPULATION GO DOWN- WE INCREASE
OUR PROGRAMMING LEVEL SO THOSE
ARE. THOSE ARE FACILITIES TAT
ARE IN PHASE THREE- ARE ABLE TO
RESUME. FULL PROGRAMMING WITH
THE CABBIE OUT THAT IN CERTAIN
AREAS SUCH AS EDUCATION
CLASSROOMS WE HAVE TO FOLLOW
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO IN THOSE AREAS WE WILL
WE WILL ADDRESS THAT BY-
HAVING. CLASSES ON DIFFERENT
DAYS OF THE WEEK WOULD ALSO-
SUBSTITUTE- IN CLASS WORK FOR
WHAT WE CALL PACKET
PROGRAMMING. I KNOW YOU ALSO
REFERENCED. A SUBSTANCE ABUSE-
WE DO HAVE A JUST OVER TEN
THOUSAND OF OUR POPULATION THAT
ARE NOW NOT MEDICATED ASSISTED
THERAPY. WE HAVE JUST OVER SIX
THOUSAND. ATTENDING COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY- TIED TO
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WE'RE
REALLY HOPING TO RESUME- FULL
IN PERSON PROGRAMMING TOOL IN
PERSON. VISITING IS SOON AS THE
GUIDANCE FROM CDPH AND CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL. ALLOW US
TO GO BACK TO OUR FULL CAPACITY
LEVELS BECAUSE WE SHARE THE
SAME CONCERNS- UNDER TRAINER
POPULATION- WINNER WHEN THEY
LEAVE OUR FACILITIES ARE
PREPARED WITH. THE RIGHT
EDUCATION THE RIGHT JOB SKILLS
AND- SUBSTANCE. FREE THANK YOU
AND I CAN OF FOR THOSE OF US ON
THE LEGISLATURE YOU BE GREAT TO
HAVE SOME THOSE NO WHEN THEY
TO. WELL GOOD NEWS STORIES ARE
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
LOOK AT THE BUDGET AND WHAT
WILL REPLACE THOSE RESOURCES
ESPECIALLY AND NOT. YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION THANK YOU FOR
THOSE RESPONSE- THERE'S STILL
A LOT THAT HAS TO BE ON I THINK
OF RECTIFIED. IN TERMS OF THE
MESSAGES THAT ARE OUT THERE SO.
I APPLAUD YOU. HARDLY FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO. THIS PARTICULAR
AGENCY AND ITS MISSION- I WILL
BE OBTAINING TODAY UNTIL WE
HAVE SOME MORE SUBSTANTIVE-
REPORTS ON. ADDRESSING THESE
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SAFETY OF WOMEN AND HOW THEY
WERE FEELING HOSPITALS SOME OF
THOSE ARE PRETTY GRAPHIC IN
TERMS OF THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE. THAT TOO AGAIN KNOW THAT
ARE YOU FEEL AFTER READING YOUR
RESUME AND SEEING ALL THE YEARS
OF SERVICE- VERY VERY
IMPRESSED- YEAH DON'T. WILL
JUST RESERVE FILED. MY BUILDING
MY JUDGMENT OF FOR A LITTLE
WHILE LONGER. I'D LIKE TO GO TO
MISS BRANDON ALLENTOWN JOB WHAT
I NOTICED ON THE ORG CHART HERE
MISS BRANDO AND- AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ON AGAIN
YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT. WHAT
THE TWO OF YOU HAVE DONE. AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT MISSION. I
APPLAUD YOU- BUT I NOTICED THAT
UNDER- YOUR ADMINISTRATION
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THIS BOX MY
GOODNESS YOU HAVE. A LOT OF
THINGS TO OVERSEE. ABOUT ONE
THAT CAUGHT MY EYE WAS HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPUTY DIRECTOR IS
VACANT UNITS THAT ACCURATE AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME BECAUSE-
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE COME OUT.
OF A REALLY ABOUT HUMAN
RESOURCES AND WHETHER THEY ARE
EFFECTIVE. IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
WITH INMATES AND STAFF AND SOME
OF THE WHAT WE CALL THE TOXIC.
OF WORK AND LIVING ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S WHAT IT SEEMS TO BE ALL
ABOUT SO IS THAT ACCURATE IN IS
THAT FALLING ON YOUR SHOULDERS
OR DO YOU HAVE SOMEONE. THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH AT THE
MOMENT. TO ADDRESS. THAT ISSUE
THANK YOU SENATE WE DO HAVE A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR HUMAN RESOURCE
BECAUSE AND IS NOT FILLED AND
IN PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN HUMAN
RESOURCES AND OUR OFFICE OF
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. OUR OFFICE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS WE HAVE A FULL
COMMITTEE THAT'S BEEN WORKING
ON VARIOUS TRAINING AND
NATIONALS TO ADDRESS B. THE
STRESS ENVIRONMENT THAT OR OR
PEACE OFFICERS ENCOUNTER IS
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT- AS
WELL AS ADDRESSING DIVERSITYEQUITY INCLUSION. FOR ALL OF
OUR STAFF WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT HAS A
NUMBER OF BUILDING BLOCKS THAT
ADDRESSES. WELLNESS IT
ADDRESSES UPWARD MOBILITY-
THINGS SUCH AS OUR DESERT
WATERS THAT PROVIDES- TRAINING
FOR OUR STAFF ON THE STRESSORS
THAT OCCUR IN THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT. AND HOW BEST TO
COPE AND ADDRESS THOSE WELL AS
STRESS RESILIENCY REALLY
EXCITED THAT WE'RE MOVING
pCHIP FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A
AT A TRAINING THAT WILL REALLY
HELP OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS WITH- DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES HOW TO
DEFUSE POTENTIALLY UNWARRANTED
ENCOUNTERS. AND OVERALL
WELLNESS FOR THE STAFF ALL
OVERSTAFFED IN CORRECTIONS
RECEIVE TRAINING ON DIVERSITY.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN DOING IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING SO WE'VE REALLY
BEEN LOOKING AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT AVENUES BETWEEN HUMAN
RESOURCES WELLNESS TRAINING
CIVIL RIGHTS TO HAVE A WILL
REALLY WELL DEVELOPED
WRAPAROUND TRAINING APPROACH
FOR STAFF VERY GOOD WILL IF I
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF THE NEXT
QUESTION THE WORKFORCE
RECRUITMENT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT TIME WITH THE PRISON
BECAUSE PRISON THE CLOSURES
THAT JOB PERHAPS THE JOBS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY THERE WILL BE
CHALLENGED AND CERTAINLY
RECEIVING NEW FOLKS FIVE TO
THAT WILL BE BE AN ISSUE I KNOW
THE PRISON PRISON CLOSURE ISSUE
WILL MOST LIKELY BE ADDRESSED
BY ANOTHER ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT TO WHAT ARE
YOU DOING IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING THE JOBS THAT ARE
THERE ON THE POTENTIAL
CLOSURES- ARE AND HOW DO YOU
RECRUIT NEW FOLKS WE ON IT YOU
ARE BASICALLY LAYING OFF ON
EXISTING STAFF BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE CRITICAL IN TERMS OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE SO
ESSENTIAL FOR REHABILITATION
AND THEN ADDRESSING SOME OF
THESE ISSUES BETWEEN. ON.
INMATES AND STAFF FIRST OFF THE
PRISON CLOSURES WE HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE STAFF AND
THE MANAGEMENT OF THOSE
LOCATIONS OUR GOAL IS TO HELP
ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES FIND
CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT WITH US.
AND AND FORTUNATELY AND IN MANY
SITUATIONS THERE MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH OF THE SAME JOB
CLASSIFICATION FOR ALL OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES IN THE SAME COUNTY.
BUT WE DO KNOW HOW THE VACANCY
FOR ALL STAFF- OUTSIDE EITHER
COUNTIES- UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT WOULD THEN MEAN THAT THERE
ARE PERHAPS MOVING FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BUT IT IS OUR GOAL
TO HELP THEM WITH- FINDING
EMPLOYMENT. WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING THAT
WORKING WITH OUR OUR LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH THE
STAFF. AND I WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT. AT THE
SAME TIME WE ARE CONSTANTLY
RECRUITING FOR VARIOUS
POSITIONS OUR DEPARTMENT
EXPANDS THE ENTIRE STATE. WE
HAVE NEARLY EVERY BARGAINING
UNIT WE HAVE NEARLY EVERY
TRADING CLASSIFICATION- AND WE
ARE OFTEN FACED WITH AT
RECRUITMENT CHALLENGES FOR-
CERTAIN LOCATIONS IN CERTAIN
JOBS. THE WAY WE MITIGATE THAT
AS WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
RECRUITMENT TEAM HE
TRANSPORTATION HAS TRAINED
RECRUITERS WE HAVE RECRUITMENT
AS HER HEADQUARTERS AS WELL- WE
NEED TO FOCUS RECRUITMENT FOR
BOTH PEACE OFFICER AND ON PEACE
OFFICER CLASSIFICATIONS. WERE
USING SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WE
ARE PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE'VE UPDATED ALL OF
OUR COMMUNICATION STRATEGIES
WITH HER OR INTERNET WEB PAGES.
AND WE ALSO DO A LOT OF FOCUS
ON DIVERSITY RECRUITMENT. WE
ARE DOING FOCUSED RECRUITMENT
FOR VETERANS OR WOMEN. FOR
LGBTQ I COMMUNITIES AND REALLY
PARTNERING WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT DIVERSITY THAT OUR
STATE REPRESENTS AND I'M DOING
OUR BEST TO RECRUIT FOR ALL OF
THOSE VARIOUS CLASSIFICATIONS.
I THINK THE BIGGEST THING IS
SHARING THAT- WE ARE. A
DEPARTMENT THAT IS ONE THAT
SOME POORBEST IS SUPER OF TO
AND MOVE AND- REALLY GETTING
THAT CONTINUED WORD OUT AS WE
HAVE WELL I THINK A- A BOTTOM
LINE ON ALL OF THIS IS THE
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON THE
PRISONS BEING AN ECONOMIC
RESOURCE TO THE COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE IS SOMETHING THAT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH IN A
VERY SENSITIVE. A MANNER- TO
UNDERMINE AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
OF- ECONOMIC WELL BEING IS OF
GREAT CONCERN WHAT HAPPENS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE NOTICE AND
PLANNING ON A FULL BEAR THAT IN
MIND THAT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT VERY CAREFULLY AND
PROBABLY WERE QUITE
DISAPPOINTED- ARE BY NOW WITH
THE LAST JOB CLOSURE WHICH I
GUESS HAS BEEN INTERCEPTED BY.
THE LEGAL SYSTEM SO WITH THAT
AGAIN THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART FOR ALL
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THEIR PHONES
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU MIGHT HAVE
STARTED WHEN YOU WERE HERE IF
YOU ARE SO- BEAUTIFUL FRANKLY
SO AND ZERO DOESN'T KNOW DO THE
BILL FOR FOLKS WHO ARE UNDER
THE PRESSURE OF ONE OF THE SUB.
INTERVIEWS BUT TOUGH
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN FOR YOUR
NOMINATION AND I WILL BE WITH
HOLDING AT THIS POINT IN TIME
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE NEED A
DEEPER DIVE. AND MAYBE MORE
CONVERSATION AND I APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE TIME IN
MY SCHEDULE. TO DO THAT JOB
PRIOR TO OUR MEETING TODAY PHIL
THANK YOU AGAIN AND- WISHING
YOU THE VERY BEST AS YOU GO
FORWARD WITH YOUR PLANS TO MAKE
A CHANGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRETENDING YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY I APOLOGIZE THAT I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO
EITHER OF YOU- BE FOR AT TODAY
BUT I'VE READ A LOT ABOUT YOU
AND I THINK THAT TIME BOTH OF
YOU ARE VERY QUALIFIED FOR THIS
POSITION AND I APPRECIATE YOU.
ACCEPTING THIS CHALLENGING
POSITION THAT TIME YOU GUYS
BOTH FIND YOURSELVES AND THINK
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF RULES
COME APPOINTMENTS WHERE I CAN
SPEAK FOR THE DIETS WERE LIKE
WELL WE WOULD NEVER WANT THAT
JOB SO OKAY BUT SO WE I A THANK
YOU GUYS FOR THAT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW
IN THE IN THE REAL WORLD I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER WE DO A LOT OF
RECRUITING HAT MISPRINT ARE YOU
MENTIONED THAT. YOU'RE DOING
RECRUITING ON SOCIAL MEDIA DID
YOU MAY OF FOCUS RECRUITING ALL
THOSE THINGS- HOW'S IT GOING
WORDS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND I'M ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN ANY ADDITIONAL.
TIPS AND SUPPORT FROM
PROFESSIONALS WITH RECRUITING
AS SENATOR SO THANK YOU- WE'RE
WE'RE SEEING A GOOD PRESENCE
THERE WE'RE GETTING. A GOOD
RESPONSE. WE'RE GETTING GOOD
INTERESTS WE KNOW THAT. SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS IS- REALLY THAT
THE NEXT STEP FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF THE WORK FORCE-
SO WE'RE INSURING THAT. AND OUR
RECRUITMENT FOR USING THOSE.
NEW METHODS OF RECRUITING ALONG
WITH THE TRADITIONAL SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY MAXIMIZE THE FULL
WORK FORCE- AND WE'RE- WE'RE
SEEING STEADY PROGRESS IT'S-
IT'S NEW. ARE WORKING TO NEARLY
TWELVE ALMOST THAT WOULD.
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE BEST
PRACTICES IN THAT SPACE. AND-
WE'RE EAGER TO DO MORE M. WE
YOU COMBINE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING THAT AS WELL AND-
WHEN YOU COMBINE WHAT YOU DOING
WITH NEW TECHNOLOGY AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND HOW WE RECRUIT I
DON'T SEE THE YOUNGER
GENERATION BUT OBVIOUSLY
YOUNGER THAN I AM. AND YOU KNOW
PEOPLE DON'T LOOK AT THE
NEWSPAPER ANYMORE IN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS- A DO YOU FIND
THE DO YOU FIND A FEWER
APPLICANTS THAN YOU DID IN SAY
TWENTY NINE NINETEEN AND THE
REASON I ASK THAT IS WE DID
EVERYTHING LAST WEEK- WHEN
WE'RE OFF FOR A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO ARRIVE THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE WERE AVERAGING
ABOUT AND JUST GIVE ME AN
EXAMPLE TURN EIGHTY FIVE
APPLICATIONS A WEEK. TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE TO
TWELVE APPLICANTS A WEEK AND
NOW IT'S FORTY APPLICANTS A
WEEK FORTY SIX APPLICANTS A
WEEK AND MMHM AND OUT OF THAT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE REQUIREMENTS I THINK THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE YOU WOULD LOSE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF THAT
PERCENTAGE RATE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW DRUG TESTING VALID
DRIVER'S LICENSE- CRIMINAL
HISTORY JUST ANY BACKGROUND
CHECKS THAT YOU DO TO BE A
CITIES HERE OFFICER. DO YOU- DO
YOU FIND YOUR APPLICATION BASE
IS LOWER THAN HAS PREVIOUSLY
BANNED WELL OUR APPLICATION
BASED OUT OVERALL WE'RE IT
DEPENDS ON THE CLASSIFICATION-
BUT AS I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO PEACE
OFFICER CLASSIFICATIONS- WE DID
SEE A SLIGHT DECLINE THIS PAST
YEAR- SIMILAR TO WHAT OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
REPORTING- BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO MITIGATE THAT BY DOING
ADDITIONAL RECRUITMENT SWEAR
PARTNERING WITH DMV AND AB DE.
UM AND DOING ADDITIONAL
RECRUITMENT WITH THEM- WE'VE
GOT SOME BILLBOARD MARKETING
MARKETING WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT AREAS
IN WHICH WE NEED TO ROUTE AND
WHAT THE BEST APPROACH IS FOR
THE PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION- FOR OTHER
CLASSIFICATIONS- WE DO SEE SOME
AREAS WHERE WE ARE HAVING AN%
INCREASE IN APPLICANTS AND
OTHER AREAS THAT WERE HAVING- A
DECREASE SIMILAR TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND- IN THE WORK
FORCE OVERALL THANK YOU IN ONCE
IS APPLICATION IS APPROVED
APPLIES AND WHAT'S THE PROCESS
I MEAN I KNOW THAT. AND IS THE
CDC ARE HAVE A SIMILAR PROCESS
LIKE AND REGULAR OF POLICE
OFFICERS SHOULD THEY GO THROUGH
SOME TYPE OF ACADEMY CENTIPEDE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. LIKE IS
THERE A PROCESS AND WHAT'S THE
LENGTH OF THAT PROCESS YES WE
DO HAVE A PROCESS FOR A LONG%
FORCE MAN- POSITIONS- THERE'S A
WRITTEN EXAMINATION AND THERE'S
A PHYSICAL FITNESS TEST THERE
IS SEE. A THOROUGH BACKGROUND A
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION AND
UPON SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF
THOSE COMPONENTS THEN THERE IS
ARE AT BASIC CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER ACADEMY. FOLLOWED BY-
ON SITE- MENTOR SHIP THAT WERE
REALLY EXCITED IS STARTING OFF
THIS YEAR I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THAT REGARD- WERE YOU OFFICERS
ARRIVED AT THE INSTITUTION AND
THEY ARE ASSIGNED TO EIGHT
MENTOR THAT CONTINUES WITH THAT
TRAINING. TO ENSURE THEIR
SUCCESS SO AM. I I'D LIKE TO
SWITCH IF I COULD TO MISTER
MARK HOMER AT. THE PRONOUNCE
THE B. SIR I APOLOGIZE. KAMBER
MCCUMBER SORRY I APOLOGIZE AND
THANK YOU MISS PERU FOR
ANSWERING THOSE QUESTIONS AND
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT I
JUST GOT FROM INSPIRADO HI AYE
MY CURIOSITY PIQUED ME THESE
WERE NOT IN MY LINE OF
QUESTIONS I WAS NOT GOING TO
ASK THESE QUESTIONS AND TELL.
AND THE FORMER SECRETARY OF TO
SPECIFIC QUESTION WHICH MADE ME
THINK ABOUT THIS PROCESS- ONLY
BECAUSE IN THE PRIVATE WORLD
IT'S KIND LIKE RIGHT UP MY
ALLEY IF THAT MAKES SENSE. SO
BASED ON ALL THAT IN YOUR
RECRUITMENT TIME- SPECIALLY FOR
THE PEACE OFFICER PORTION WHICH
I'M ASSUMING OR THIS THE- THE
GUARDS THIS FOR LAYMAN'S TERM
GUARDS. AND PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY DO THAT THE
PROTECTION OR THE GUARDS IN THE
SYSTEM. AS IT. YOU HAVE SAID
EARLIER THAT 53% OF THE STAFF
INCLUDING THE GUARDS ARE-
VACCINATED OR NOT- VACCINATED
53% MY COLLEAGUE IN. THE EAST
THE FORMER SECRETARY. OF WOULD
LIKE THAT NUMBER TO BE HIGHER.
MY QUESTION IS THAT- AS I'M
JUST GONNA BE HONEST I GOT
PEOPLE CALLING ME LEFT AND
RIGHT AND- SEVERAL OF THEM ARE
FIREFIGHTERS TEACHERS NURSES
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE CDC ARE.
THE GUARDS WHAT HAPPENS IF I
MEAN. DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH BACKUP
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN THROUGH
THE TRAINING ACADEMY SKILLED
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL PEOPLE
THAT COULD TAKE THESE POSITIONS
IF MANDATES ARE REQUIRED IN
YOUR- YOU LOSE STAFF AT
FIDELITY SESSION I'M SORRY I
INTERRUPTED YOU CENTER OKAY
TOTALLY FINE I SHOULDN'T SPOKE
OVER YOU I APOLOGIZE ON JAN
SHOULD THE QUESTION IF OR FACED
WITH THE SITUATION WHERE WE
HAVE- INSUFFICIENT STAFF WE
HAVE STAFFING PLANS FOR EACH
INSTITUTION TO RUN AT REDUCED
LEVELS. OF STANDARDS CALLED YOU
KNOW FIRST LUNCH PLANS- SO WERE
ABLE TO STILL RUN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO THE POPULATION
MEETING THINGS LIKE FEEDING AND
HEALTH CARE- SHOWERS AND THINGS
ALONG THOSE LINES- YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW VACCINES ARE NOT
MANDATORY- THROUGHOUT THE
PRISON SYSTEM- AND SO THERE IS
THE ABILITY RIGHT NOW FOR US TO
WORK WITHIN THAT- CURRENT-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. ORDER BUT WE DO
MAINTAIN PLANS ARE PREPARED.
SHOULD WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE PLANS THE YOU THAT'S GOOD
TO KNOW M. I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NOT A DIGITAL
PRISON CLOSERS BECAUSE WE CAN'T
FIND INDIVIDUALS TO WORK IN THE
PRESENTS THAT. AND CHOOSE NOT
TO GET VACCINATED SO THAT'S A
SEPARATE QUESTION I WAS BEING
ASKED THAT QUESTION AND TO LIVE
IT WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER. DO
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT PRISON
CLOSURES AND I'M NOT PARTICULAR
ABOUT WHO ANSWERS IT EITHER ONE
OF YOU CAN TAKE A SHOT AT IT OR
BOTH OF YOU- F. M. BASED ON
COUNT FROM CAL FIRE TODAY THERE
ARE EIGHTEEN FIRES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF THEM HAS
AND- CONSUMED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES THE DIXIE FIRE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND HOW
MANY FIRE CAMPS AND THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH CDCR FIRE
TRAINING FACILITIES FIRE
CAMPFIRE. WHATEVER IT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THIRD THE- LEGAL TERM
IS CALLED HOW WE START THEIR
WHAT'S THE LEGAL TERM FOR FIRE
TRAINING FACILITIES FOR YOUTH
CONSERVATION CAMPS- ARE IN MAY
FIRING CAPS ARE ARE SOME OF THE
TERMS WE UTILIZE OKAY SO HOW
MANY OF THOSE CONSERVATION
CAMPS AND- HAVE CLOSE CENTER OR
A FOR CLOSURE SO PROXIMATE LI I
THINK A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
WE CLOSED I BELIEVE IT WAS A
FIVE- FIREFIGHTING CAMPS- DUE
TO THE DECLINING ELIGIBLE ON A
CAR CITY POPULATION WE WERE
STRUGGLING TO GET THE NUMBERS
WE ONCE DEAD AND SO WE'RE
RUNNING A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
VACANCIES. AS A RESULT OF THE
POTENTIAL CLOSURE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL CENTER-
THE CAMPS THAT ARE TIED TO THAT
FACILITY WILL ALL BE
TRANSFERRED TO SIERRA
CONSERVATION CENTER SO WE DO
NOT PLAN TO CLOSING ANY CABS AS
A RESULT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL CENTER CLOSURE IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. OKAY M. I.
ASSET FOR TWO REASONS NUMBER
ONE THERE SO MANY FIRES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT TIME YOU KNOW OUR
FAMILY ALSO HAS RANCH PROPERTY
AND I GOT A TEXT FROM MY
HUSBAND ONE DAY HE WAS THERE'S
A FIRE AT THE RANCH. ABOUT
THIRTY MINUTES LATER HE SAID
THE RANCHES ON FIRE. AND I LIVE
SACRAMENTO AND I WENT THERE
WHEN I GOT THERE IT WAS REALLY
AMAZING TO ME HOW- AGAIN. I
DON'T KNOW THE LEGAL TERM FORM
AT THE END MAKERS OF THE CREWS
THAT CAME FROM CDC ARE WHICH
YOU KNOW WHERE THE SHOVEL THE
PICK THAT. YOU KNOW THE
BREAKING LINE AT NIGHT AND- HOW
THEY WORKED SO WELL WITH CAL
FIRE IN THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
THERE- AS A COHESIVE TEAM TO
ELIMINATE. AND THE FIRE I SAW
FIRST HAND HAVE BEEN THERE
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF THE
PROPERTY- YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE
PROPERTY BUT- M. AND THEN I
TALKED TO SOME OF THEM OF
COURSE I WENT AND START TALKING
TO A LOT OF THEM CAN I TALK TO
SOME OF THEM AND I ASKED HIM.
IF THEY HAD HEARD YOU KNOW WHY
DID YOU TAKE THIS CLASS WHERE
YOU WANT TO BE HERE THEY TALKED
ABOUT HOW IT'S BENEFICIAL IN
REDUCTION OF SENTENCE TIME AND
THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
SKILL SET THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
WHEN THEY- LEAVE SO THAT THEY
COULD ACTUALLY. HAVE SKILLS AND
TO HELP THEM STAY OUT OF PRISON
AND TO HELP TEM HAVE A JOB TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
BECAUSE IN REALITY THAT'S ALL
THEY REALLY WANT TO DO WHEN
THEY GET OUT A LOT OF THEM. AND
SO THAT WHAT IS WHAT ARE YOU
DOING OR WHAT'S THE FACILITIES
OR CDC ARE DOING IF THESE
TRAINING A CONSERVATION CAMPS.
WHICH WOULD GET THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE TRAINING-
OBVIOUS IT'S HARD WORK BUT
TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO WORK IN
THIS TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT. AND
YOU TO BE ABLE PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES SO WHAT'S THE
SUBSTITUTE IF WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TRAINING TO FIGHT FIRES WHEN
WE NEED FIREFIGHTERS OBVIOUSLY
EVERYBODY'S- ON THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT RESOURCES AND THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH DOES NOT OF FIREFIGHTERS
NOT OF ANYTHING THAT'S WHY THEY
CAN'T PUT IT. YOU KNOW THIS AT
THE CONTAINMENT ON THESE FIRES
IS STILL LOW WHAT'S THE
SUBSTITUTE TRAINING SO THAT YOU
KNOW YOU CAN'T TRYING TO FLIP
BURGERS THEY CAN'T RAISE PLAN
TO GET RESERVE FAMILY ON THAT.
SO WHAT'S THE SUBSTITUTE
TRAINING THAT YOU'RE OFFERING
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM THEM IF THAT'S A
THAT'S A LONG. QUESTION BUT- I
WILL BE TO GET THE BEST NOT A
GREAT BECAUSE WE WILL I HAVE
THE KIND WE ALWAYS WANT TO
ENSURE INDIVIDUALS ARE REALLY
SICK BACK TO THE COMMUNITY YOUR
ECLIPSE. WITH THE RESOURCES TO
BE PRODUCTIVE AND- YOU KNOW
USUALLY THAT MEANS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR A GED- WE DO
HAVE. A VERY LARGE NUMBER OF
OUR INCARCERATED POPULATION NOW
ENROLLED AND- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME PILOT
PROGRAMS WERE. WE RECENTLY SAW-
ABOUT TEN OF OUR- POPULATION
GOD. BA DEGREES FROM CAL STATE
LOS ANGELES WHICH WERE VERY
PLEASED ABOUT SO WE LOOK TO DO.
NOT ONLY EDUCATION BUT WE HAVE-
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
COURSES THAT THEY RUN THE WHOLE
GAMBIT COULD BE- AUTO BODY
REPAIR OR IT COULD BE
AUTOMOTIVE MECHANICS- IT COULD
BE- THE SUITE OF MICROSOFT
PRODUCTS AND LEARNING THAT
COMPUTER PROCESS. AND SO WE
LOOK AT. THE JOBS THAT- GOOD
THE PEOPLE IN THE REAL WORLD
ARE GOING TO NEED WE TRY TO
TARGET- OUR EDUCATION CLASSES.
TO LINE UP WITH THOSE DATES OF
WHEN THEY WERE LEASE- THEY
ACTUALLY HOW RELEASING WITH THE
SKILL. I MEAN I KNOW YOU ALSO
BROUGHT UP YOU KNOW NOT
TRAINING- IS MANY FIREFIGHTERS
WHICH ARE OUR CAMP FIVE
POLLUTION IS DOWN BUT I DO WANT
TO. RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS AND HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AND- ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WHICH
ACTUALLY ALLOWS- SOME OF OUR
OTHER CAR CERTIFIED PLACES. TO
ALLOW THEM TO APPLY FOR
FIREFIGHTING JOBS IN THE
COMMUNITY- SO WE THINK THAT'S A
GREAT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT'S A VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE I
AM BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THAT
WAS JUST SAID- WHEN I GO BACK
TO THAT THE VACCINE- QUESTION
YOU SAID SEVENTY EIGHT. WHEN
YOU WERE SPEAKING MISTER
MCOMMERCE SEVENTY WHAT PERCENT
OF THE INMATES ARE VACCINATED.
I BELIEVE 74% 74% ALSO- BUT I
JUST GET THAT QUESTION I'LL
SKIP THAT QUESTION SORRY I'LL
SKIP THAT QUESTION M. WELL I
REALLY AM GLAD THAT YOU HAVE A
AND AN ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM TO
BE ABLE TO- YOU KNOW HELP
PEOPLE SUCCEED OUTSIDE THE
PRISON SYSTEM I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT TIME. I
THINK THE BEST SOLUTION TO
POVERTY IS A JOB AT THE BEST
SOLUTION OF PROPERTY BEST
SOLUTION TO SELF RESPECT
DIGNITY PROVIDING FOR YOUR
FAMILY. IS A JOB IN AND MY HUGE
CONCERN IS- IS THAT- WITHOUT
THIS TRAINING. AS THEY'LL BE
MINIMAL JOBS AVAILABLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WOULD BE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED. BUT I
DO THANK YOU FOR- EXPLAINED TO
ME THAT YOU DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
AND TRAINING SO THAT THEY CAN
BE SUCCESSFUL OUTSIDE OF THE
PRISON SYSTEM. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU BOTH FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE IT. AND AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
TAKE ON THIS- POSITION
ESPECIALLY. IN A COPA SITUATION
WE HAVE LIMITED YOU KNOW I MEAN
BASICALLY YOU JUST HAVE LIMITED
FACILITY SPACE. AND YOU KNOW
WHEN ROLES GOING TO PLACE ABOUT
SOCIAL DISTANCE SCENE AND- AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WHICH YOU KNOW
ARE NECESSARY TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE- I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
VERY DIFFICULT I MEAN IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR US HERE IN THE
SENATE. I GUESS YOU WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE LIMITED SPACE
WE HAD TO. YOU KNOW PUT THINGS
IN PLACE SO IT IS- IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT AND I THINK YOU GUYS
FOR BEING WILLING TO PURSUE.
THIS POSITION IN THIS CAREER-
IN THESE TROUBLING TIMES ARE
TRYING TIMES THAT WE HAVE SO
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS AND I WISH YOU
BOTH THE VERY BEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW- SENATOR KAMAKA THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- THANK YOU I DO
LIKE GOING LAUGHED BECAUSE
FOLKS ASK FOR MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE LISTED- I
WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR-
SPENDING TIME OUT OF YOUR DAY
YESTERDAY TO TALK WITH ME- AND
WHAT I THOUGHT WE HAD SOME VERY
GOOD DISCUSSIONS VERY HONEST
WHICH I ALWAYS APPRECIATE AND I
HAVE TO SAY TO ECHO- THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR VICE
CHAIR. I HAVE INCREDIBLE
RESPECT FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT
THAT KIND OF TIME IN YEARS THAT
YOU HAVE BOTH COMMITTED- TO
THIS PROFESSION AND TO THE
SYSTEM- IT HAS YOU HAVE
PROBABLY SEEN HERKY JERKY NESS-
OF ALL SORTS AND SO THE FACT
THAT YOU ALL HAVE- THEY THE
COURSE I THINK SPEAKS VOLUMES-
TELL TO THE CHANGE THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO SEE- HAPPEN. I ALSO
BELIEVE- THAT. BOTH WORK AND
THE PUNISHMENT ON THAT NEITHER
SHOULD BE- BEREFT OF HUMANITY.
OR DIGNITY- AND I THINK
OFTENTIMES WITH THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE ASK- IN RULES ARE
RELATED TO CDC ARE- POSITIONS
IT'S YOU KNOW HOW TO FIND AND
HOW TO GET ASSURANCES THAT
FOLKS ARE THINKING ABOUT WAYS
TO RUN AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED. AND LARGE SYSTEM
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE-
INSERTING- HUMANITY AND DIGNITY
AND BOTH HOUSING PERSUADED
FOLKS WHO TREATED BUT THEN ALSO
HOW FOLKS ARE TREATED WHO ARE
ACTUALLY GOING THERE EVERY DAY
TO DO THE WORK SO- I HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR BOTH OF YOU I'M
GOING TO ASK THE QUESTION I
THINK BOTH OF YOU ALL CAN
ANSWER IT AND IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF YOU COULD JUST ANSWER IT
BASED ON. YOUR JURISDICTION-
AND THE YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
AND I KNOW FOR MISTER MCCUMBER
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING FROM ADMIN
TO ADMINISTRATION YOU PROBABLY
FROM ADMIN OPERATIONS YOU
PROBABLY HAVE- ALL SORTS OF
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU COULD
SHARE BUT- I THINK YOU- IT'S
LIKE YOU KNOW A AND B. MY FINAL
THING. I'M SO THE MISSION
STATEMENT FOR CDC ARE WOULD YOU
KIND OF NEVER REALLY READ THE
MISSION STATEMENT- FOR THESE-
DEPARTMENTS BUT I DID- AND I
HAD TO COME BACK TO IT BECAUSE
EACH OF YOU AND YOUR RESPONSES
KIND OF TALKED ABOUT- HOW
CULTURE CHANGE. IS HARD AND HOW
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS THAT.
REALLY DON'T BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION IN THE
REHABILITATION AND CDCR YOU
BOTH ALSO MENTIONED THAT- THERE
ARE A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
COMMITTED PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING AND DOING THEIR BEST IN
THE SYSTEM. BUT OF COURSE THAT
NUMBER IS NOT A 100% TO BE FAIR
THAT NUMBER'S NOT A 100%
ANYWHERE- BUT JUST WANTED TO
HEAR FROM YOU- BECAUSE I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT TRAINING DOESN'T
WORK WITHOUT BRIAN RIGHT
WITHOUT MODELING- AND YOU BOTH
DID TALK ABOUT TRAINING SO JUST
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS AGAIN ABOUT. YOU KNOW
HOW HOW DOES THE MISSION CHANGE
GET ACTIVATED- WHEN THERE ARE
DISSENTERS- THAT ARE IN THEIR
RANKS- THAT ARE ON THE GROUND.
GIVEN THE REALLY COMPLICATED-
AND DANGEROUS TASKS IN SOME
INSTANCES THAT YOU ALL- ARE
FORCED TO MANAGE- IT'S A SLOW
PROCESS I'VE BEEN TOLD- I CAN
BE A PAINFUL PROCESS I'M TOLD
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S STILL
REALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT THE FEDS
TELL US WE HAVE TO MAKE CHANGE.
LEGISLATORS TELL YOU YOU HAVE
TO MAKE CHANGE AND PROBABLY
WITHIN YOUR OWN- YOU KNOW
INTERNAL SESSIONS YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE CHANGE YOU NEED TO
SEE TO KEEP YOUR EMPLOYEES SAFE
AND HAPPY- TO RETAIN THEM. TO
RECRUIT NEW FOLKS INTO THE
SYSTEM WE'RE GOING TO HELP TO
MAKE THE SYSTEM ACTIVE AND
ULTIMATELY- TO DO RIGHT BY WHAT
THE CHARGES SO CAN YOU BOTH
SORT OF TALK ABOUT IT FROM YOUR
OWN PERSPECTIVE- HOW YOU.
ACTIVATE THE MISSION GIVEN THE
FACT THAT YOU DO HAVE FOLKS
THAT ARE NOT REALLY INTERESTED
IN IT YOU CERTAINLY I CAN START
THIS ONE- JEFF BUT- SENATOR
YOU'RE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
EACH TIME WE MAKE A CHANGE EACH
TIME THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD-
THERE ARE THERE ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE SOME STAFF BETTER
OR NOT ON ON BOARD. AND THERE
WILL ALSO BE STAFF THAT ARE
EARLY ADOPTERS AND WHO HELPED
US TO MAKE THE CHANGE HAPPEN
RATHER SWIFTLY- WE SEE NOT IN
OUR HISTORY WE SEEN THAT IN
RECENT HISTORY. I MYSELF HAVE
SEEN IT PERSONALLY- I WAS IN
THE APARTMENT I'VE BEEN HRE
FOR SOME TIME. BUT WAS HERE
WHEN WE MADE THE- SWITCH FROM
CDC TWO CDC ARE. AND AT THAT
TIME- THERE WERE STAFF THAT
WERE ABSOLUTELY ON BOARD AND
EAGER TO SEE OUR TRANSFORMATION
HAPPENED. AND THERE WERE SOME
THAT WERE QUITE FRANKLY NOT ON
BOARD- WE HAVE STAFF THAT HAVE
BEEN WITH US FOR MANY YEARS- WE
HAVE STAFF THAT SOMETIMES- HAVE
DIFFICULTY WITH CHANGE. BUT
WHAT I'VE FOUND IS THE MAJORITY
OF OUR STAFF ARE EAGER FOR THE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES THEY SEE
GREAT VALUE AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING. IT GIVES THEM A GREAT
HOPE AND WHAT WE'RE DOING BY A
REHABILITATING THE POPULATION
AND HELPING THEM TO SUCCEED. I
THINK STAFF ARE REALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL THE TRAINING
AND WELLNESS INITIATIVES THAT
WE'RE DOING AND WE CAN SEE THAT
BY THEIR SUPPORT BY JOINING S
AS AMBASSADORS. FOR OUR GABBERT
GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE OF RECENT
EQUITY TEAMS THAT ARE EACH
INSTITUTION WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED STAFF THAT ARE
VOLUNTEERED. TO HELP US IN
MUNICH HE WITH THEIR PEERS WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH ADVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION. WE CAN SEE IT
BY THE AMBASSADOR PROGRAM FOR
THE INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT- MEDICATED
ASSISTED THERAPY PROGRAM WHERE
WE HAVE STAFF. OF OVER A
THOUSAND OF THEM NOW. YOUR OUT
THERE CAMPAIGNING FOR THAT
PROGRAM. SO THE BEST. WAY FOR
US TO MAKE A CULTURE SHOCK IS
LEADER AND THAT HAPPENING WITH
VARIOUS LEADERSHIP TRAININGS WE
HAVE A LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
CONTRACTED OUT WITH EXPERTS.
OUR USING OUR AT UC SYSTEMS AND
OUR- COLLEGE SYSTEMS TO HELP US
WITH SELECTING VARIOUS
TRAININGS AND NOT SPACE. AND
ALSO USING THE STAFF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE DOING THAT DAY TO DAY
WORK- HAVING THEM ON BOARD WITH
WHERE WE'RE HEADED AND
COMMUNICATING THAT TO THEIR
PEERS. AS LONG AS AS WELL AS
HAVING A MESSAGE FROM FROM
CENTRAL OFFICE.
ANDRIY FACILITY
AND I KNEW THE ANSWER OF COURSE
WE HAD DONE IN THE LAST YEAR.
WHERE AS THE FOLKS THAT MAY
HAVE NOT HAD THEIR TURN COME UP
TO BE IN EDUCATION SLOT WHO
WERE YOU KNOW SPENT THE DAY ARE
THE ARE WE WERE HAVING INSTANCE
EVERY DAY. SO I LIKE WE HAVE
PROGRAMS NUMBER ONE BECAUSE IT
GIVES THE POPULATION OF
SOMETHING CONSTRUCTIVE TO DO-
WE WANT FOLKS TO WHOM IN THE
PAST MAJORITY OF OUR POPULATION
RELEASES AT SOME POINT WE WANT
THEM TO RELEASE WITH THE TOOLS.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. WE DO NOT
WANT FOLKS COMING BACK- WITH
THE HIGH RECIDIVISM RATE- YOU
KNOW GOING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AND CYCLING IN AND
OUT OF PRISON OUR JOB SHOULD BE
TO FIX THOSE INDIVIDUALS I
THINK YOU YOU HAVING A GOOD
POINT ABOUT HOW DO YOU GET
STAFF TO BUY AND I DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. GO TO VALLEY
STATE PRISON- THIS PAST MONDAY.
AND I TALKED TO SOME
INDIVIDUALS IN IN ONE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OF ONE OF THE
COUNSELORS THAT CORDING SUMMER
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER PROGRAM AND
WERE KIND OF TARGETING- OUR
PRIMARY NORWAY MODEL
ADDITIONALLY IS AT THAT
FACILITY AND I ASKED HIM I
SAID. YOU KNOW DID YOU ALWAYS
HAVE A PASSION FOR THIS TO PUSH
HOUSTON TO BETTER THEMSELVES
AND- UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS TO
YOU AND OTHERS ARE THE PROGRAM
HE SAID NO I DIDN'T HE SAID I
HAD TO GO TO A CLASS AND I SAW
WHAT WAS POSSIBLE AND I TOOK IT
BACK TO THE SUBSTITUTION I
STARTED IMPLEMENTING IT AND IS
IT RESULTED IN NOT ONLY. THE
INMATE POPULATION DE STRESSING
BUT IT ALSO RESULTED IN THE
STAFF STRESS LEVEL COMING DOWN
WHICH IS PART OF THE KEY
COMPONENT OF THE NORWAY MODEL
IS NOT JUST ABOUT- THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION BUT
IT'S HOW THAT'S THE STAFF
INTERACT AND- CAN'T CAN DO SO
IN A LESS STRESSFUL
ENVIRONMENT. AND MAYBE MORE
FRIENDLY BUT NOT OVER FAMILIAR
ENVIRONMENT SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE STAFF UNDERSTANDS- THAT
THEY CAN BENEFIT FROM SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS AS WELL AND WE
NEED TO DO A GOOD JOB OF
GETTING THAT MESSAGE DOWN TO
MAKE SURE IT'S NOT WATER DOWN
AS IT COMES DOWN FOR MYSELF FOR
MISS BROWN. UNTIL IT GETS DOWN
TO THAT THE LION CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT MESSAGE- I GUESS IT JUST
DOESN'T WATER DOWN IS A STRONG
MESSAGE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND THANK YOU FOR TALKING
ABOUT- STAFF AND WHAT THEY NEED
TO HEAR- BECAUSE MY NEXT
QUESTION KIND OF RELATES TO
THAT AND IT'S ABOUT AIMS- THE
AIMS PROCESS AND YOU KNOW FROM
WHAT I'VE BEEN READING- THE
FOLKS DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE- IN THE PROCESS
RIGHT NOW IT'S KIND OF A
CLUSTER- BUT- THAT'S A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD- FOR
YOU TO HAVE- STALL OUR ALLIES
WHEN PEOPLE READ IN THE NEWS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW STAFF
COMMITTING SUICIDE AROUND SORT
OF BULLYING AND INTIMIDATION-
BY STAFF- TO OTHER STAFF- IT'S
HARD WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING- YOU KNOW I'M DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT YOU KNOW NOT
ONLY OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE INCARCERATED IN THE
SAFETY OF THEM- BUT ALSO THE
STAFF- AND FOLKS WHO ARE
HETEROSEXUAL THERE'S AN UPTICK
IN MALE RAPE THAT'S HAPPENING
NOT JUST IN OUR PRISONS BUT
ALSO IN OUR JAILS AND IT IS
REALLY HARD- WHEN STAFF AND
FOLKS WERE INCARCERATED FEEL
LIKE- A COMPLAINT PROCESS IS
NOT REALLY DESIGNED. TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS TO DE ESCALATE- THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU FACE SO
LOTS OF CHALLENGES LOTS OF
SHORTFALLS IN YOUR OPINION-
FROM EACH OF YOUR PERSPECTIVE
HOW DO WE IMPROVE UPON THE
SYSTEM OR I DON'T WANNA SAY
SCRAP IT AND DEVELOP A NEW ONE
BUT HOW IS THERE. THAT WE CAN
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT ENGENDERS
SOME TRUST AND CONFIDENCE FROM
ALL OF ITS USERS BECAUSE IF
PEOPLE DON'T USE IT IT'S NOT
GONNA WORK AND IF PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE IT'S SWISS CHEESE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO USE IT AND IT'S
NOT GONNA WORK- AND THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO COME UP IN
FRONT OF US AGAIN. AND PEOPLE
ARE GONNA GET SALTIER AND
SALTIER ABOUT WHY THINGS AREN'T
WORKING SO BUT YOU'LL HAVE BEEN
HERE FOR A REALLY LONG TIME SO
I HAVE TO BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOME
IDEAS WELL SENATOR- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR THIS QUESTION YOU
BRING UP SOME VALID POINTS-
WITH OUR OUR STAFF. FIRST HIT
TO TALK ABOUT OUR STAFF. WE
HAVE A ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY.
OR ANY DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION OR BOWLING. AND WE
HAVE A WELL DEVELOPED SYSTEM OF
INFORMING STAFF OF THAT
REQUIREMENT THEY'RE TRAINED ON
IT ANNUALLY AND SUPERVISORS ARE
TRAINED ON THEIR OBLIGATION TO
REPORT. AND WE HAVE TRAINED AT
ITO COUNSELORS AND
COORDINATORS. THROUGHOUT EVERY
INSTITUTION. STAFF KNOW WHO
THEY ARE THERE'S PICTURE BOARDS
AVAILABLE TO KNOW WHO THEY ARE
WE CAN GO TO IF YOU'RE
ENCOUNTERING ANY OF THE I STAFF
MADE AWARE OF HOW THEY CAN FILE
WITH THAT APART OR OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT WITH EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING- SO
WE DO A LOT A LOT IN THAT AREA
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR- STAFF
FOR STATE. AS IT RELATES TO
AIMS- IT WAS NOT OUR INTENT TO
BUILD A SYSTEM THAT NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS WE ARE FINDING
OUT. THERE IS A NUMBER OF AREAS
THAT REQUIRE IMPROVEMENT IN
THAT SYSTEM WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING SO- WE TOOK AT TOOK AND
ALL OF THE INFORMATION FROM THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT WE TOOK AND ALL OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND- INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE AND- AND PLAINTIFFS
WITH SOME OF OUR CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT. AND I WE'VE TAKEN A
HARD LOOK AT THAT AND WE
STARTED MAKING SOME IMMEDIATE
ADJUSTMENTS- DOES INCLUDE AT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF.
IMPLEMENTING ALL ALLEGATIONS
MADE BY THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. THAT ARE RELATED TO
ANY TYPE OF USE OF FORCE OR
PRIA. THEY WILL LEAVE THE
INSTITUTION ND GO TO OUR
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
ALLOCATION AND CREAM MANAGEMENT
SECTION. THAT SOMETHING THAT
WAS SUPPORTED- IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
SUPPORT. AND WE ARE GEARING UP
TO IMPLEMENT THAT CHANGE- THIS
FALL. WE ARE ALSO- IMPLEMENTING
A CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM.
WE RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR IT TO
BE AN INDEPENDENT REVIEW EACH
GRIEVANCE THAT SUBMITTED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AT THE INSTITUTION.
THAT IT NEEDS TO LEAVE THE
INSTITUTION CURFEW AND GO TO A
CENTRALIZED INDEPENDENT OFFICE
TO EVALUATOR FOR ANY
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. SO THAT IT CAN BE
PROPERLY ASSIGNED SO THAT WE
CAN TRACK IT SO WE CAN HAVE
DATA AND METRICS TO IDENTIFY
ANY HOT SPOTS. ARE AND WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS THE GOAL OF
HAVING THAT EMPLOYMENT AND.
BEGINNING AS SOON AS JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR D. ARE OUR SOME OF
OUR STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING- WE
ARE ALSO IMPLEMENTING ANY
ALLEGATION OF STAFF ALLEGATION
TRACKING SYSTEM THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO HAVE BEEN AT A-
TECHNOLOGY BASED SOLUTION FIRST
HAVE AN AUTOMATED TRACKING
SYSTEM. SO START TO FINISH WITH
A STAFF MISCONDUCT COMPLAINT WE
CAN TRACK- ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS TO IT. AGAIN FOR US
TO HELP US TO BETTER EVALUATE-
ANY HOT SPOTS TO EVALUATE ANY
TRENDS AND WITH THE OVERALL
GOAL OF KEEPING THE POPULATION
STATE SAFE AND THAT THE STAFF
ACCOUNTABLE- NOT ALL OF OUR
STAFF MAKE. BAD DECISIONS. BUT
WHEN STAFF DO YOU MAKE A BAD
DECISION OR VIOLATE A POLICY IT
IS ABSOLUTELY OUR REQUIREMENT.
AND OUR EXPECTATION THAT
THEY'RE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
THAT I DON'T WANT AS WELL I
THINK THIS BRIDAL GIVING A
GREAT COMPREHENSIVE ANSWER SO I
WON'T REPEAT WHAT SHE'S ALREADY
SAID BUT- IS FAR AS I WILL ADD
A LITTLE CREATE COMPONENTS- WE
DO HAVE A ROBUST- STAFF
TRAINING PLAN- RELATIVE TO PRE-
IN REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
THEIR REQUIREMENTS. ALSO VERY
ENCOURAGED ABOUT RECENT FUNDING
WE RECEIVED- TO PUT IN NOT ONLY
FIX CAMERAS- BUT ALSO A LIVE
BODY WORN CAMERAS IT'S SIX
INSTITUTIONS WHICH I THINK.
WILL DEFINITELY HELP IN THIS
ARENA- WE ALSO HAVE A ROBUST
AUDITING PROCESS WERE ACTUALLY.
OTHER STATES COME CALIFORNIA
HONOR ARE PRETTY SO I THINK WE
HAVE THE RIGHT TOOLS IN PLACE I
THINK- WE WERE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR WAR-
CAMERAS THANK THAT IS A BIG
PIECE WE DID SEE. DECREASES AND
PREA COMPLAINTS WAIT DID-
INSTALL CAMERAS AT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY AND
SO I THINK THAT'S A BIG PIECE
OF THIS PUZZLE THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU BOTH FOR THAT
AND I WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU MISTER MCCUMBER BECAUSE IF
YOU MENTION THE BODY CAMERAS.
SO HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT TURNED OFF
DURING KEY EXCHANGES I MEAN HOW
DOES THAT WORK. D. YEAH BECAUSE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. THE
REVIEWING THE FOOTAGE IS
COMPLAINT DRIVEN THAT'S CORRECT
SO. LIKE I KNOW THAT I'M GOING
TO HAVE A JUMP OFF ON MY TURN
THE CAMERA OFF YOU KNOW SOUL
SOUL THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
ONE STOP TURN THE CAMERA OFF
THEY SHOULD BE STATING THE
REASON WHY AND THE STAFF. AT
THOSE FACILITIES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED BY WARRING CAMPS OF
ALL. RECEIVE TRAINING ON WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO TURN A
CAMERA OBVIOUSLY THINGS LIKE-
USING A RESTROOM- WHILE THEY'RE
DOING A HEALTH CARE
APPOINTMENTS. S. KOREA HEALTH
CARE APPOINTMENTS FOR A MEMBER
OF THE INCARCERATED POPULATION-
IF THEY'RE DOING AN UNCLE BODY
SEARCH- OVER THE COURSE FOR
INDIVIDUAL THAT THAT THAT WOULD
BE A TIME WHEN YOU TURN IT OFF-
IN THE CAR SHOULD POPULATION
DOES- WHEN THOSE CAMERAS ARE ON
A ROSTER THERE'S A LIGHT THAT
SHOWS WHETHER IT'S ON OR NOT
AND IT WOULD BE A RED FLAG
CLEARLY IF THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT. AND THE OFFICER DID
NOT HAVE THEIR BODY WORN CAMERA
ACTIVATED WHICH IS WHY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. NOT ONLY WE
HAVE THE BODY WORN CAMERAS WE
HAVE THE SIX CAMERAS AS WELL.
AS HELP GIVE US THE FULL
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON SO I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I JUST HAVE
ONE FINAL QUESTION AND I-
MISTER ADAMANT AND DID WE WANT
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM MAKING
BAD DECISIONS. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT BAD DECISIONS HAVE BEEN
ALL THE TIME. IT'S JUST A PART
OF LIFE- IT TO HOW WE LEARN
FROM THEM IS THE THING WHICH I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
ALSO SORT OF THAT SUGGESTING.
SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE BAD
DECISIONS THAT I'M INTERESTED
IN IT SOME OF THE PREDATORY
DECISIONS AND THE REASON WHY I
STAY FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE WAS
BECAUSE- A FRIEND OF MINE- HIS
SON. WAS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER- AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
DEEPER THAN HIM NOT FEELING
SAFE BECAUSE HE'S NOT WITH US
ANYMORE- AND THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE
HE WAS. A YOUNG MAN WITH A
FAMILY AND A BRIGHT FUTURE- AND
THEN I ALSO KNOW SOMEONE WHO IS
INCARCERATED- WHO WAS RECENTLY
SODOMIZED MULTIPLE TIMES JUST
IN ONE DAY. AND SO WHILE HE IS-
INCARCERATED BECAUSE OF A CRIME
HE COMMITTED- HE CERTAINLY
DOESN'T NEED TO BE TREATED LIKE
THAT AND SO I THINK ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE- WHEN I'M- BEFORE YOU OR
ANYONE ELSE ASKING QUESTIONS AS
IT RELATES TO CDCR MY LAST
QUESTION IS REALLY FOR MISTER
MCCUMBER WE BROUGHT THIS WE
CHATTED ABOUT THIS- IN THE
CLOSURE OF DJJ I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD SHARE. YOUR
THOUGHTS ON- HOW THAT IS GOING-
AND ALSO HOW WE CAN BE PARTNERS
WITH YOU AND CDCR AND MAKING
SURE THAT THIS HAPPENS- IN A
WAY THAT IS PRODUCTIVE
CONSTRUCTIVE AND ALTERNATELY
SUCCESSFUL- BECAUSE IT'S A HUGE
ENDEAVOR RIGHT THERE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES- YOU DID SHARE
THAT THERE IS A PLAN IN PLACE.
BUT YOU KNOW PLANS ON PAPER ARE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE REAL WORLD AND
WE CERTAINLY- WE ALL WANT THIS
TO COME OUT OKAY- CAN YOU IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN
SHARE WITH US ABOUT SORT OF
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AND- AND HOW
WE CAN BE PARTNERS WITH THIS OF
COURSE- WE ARE- ACTIVELY-
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY'S AND
ANSTY PARK AS WELL ON THIS
TRANSITION. AS YOU MENTIONED
IT'S WE HAVE FIFTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES THAT MAY HAVE A FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT IDEAS ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT- SKEWS ME THIS
TRANSITION WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE- TO HALL
WE'RE GOING TO SAFELY AND YOU
KNOW FAIRLY GO THROUGH THIS
TRANSITION I BELIEVE THE
DEADLINE FOR THAT IS JANUARY-
THAT WAS REPORT IS DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WE ARE ALSO VERY
MUCH. OF STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW-
YOU HAVE NOT ONLY STAFF BUT YOU
HAVE THE USE THAT ARE AWARE OF
THAT FACILITY IS CLOSING SO
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION AND
UNCERTAINTY FOR THOSE FOLKS AND
OUT START WITH STAFF- KNOWING
THAT THAT DJJ IS SLATED TO
OFFICIALLY CLOSE IN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. A LOT OF STAFF
FOR RIGHT NOW LOOKING FOR THE
NEXT OPPORTUNITY- THEY DON'T
WANT TO FACE LAYOFFS THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE AT- THE END OF THE
LINE WHEN IT COMES TO FINDING A
NEW JOB AND SO. WE'RE SEEING
FOLKS BE PROACTIVE AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING- SOME CREATIVE
OPTIONS TO DO- SOME- EARLY-
TRANSFER PROCESSES WERE WILL
GUARANTEE A SPOT IN ADULT
PRISON- FOUR OF THOSE.
CORRECTIONAL OF PEACE OFFICERS
WERE LOOKING AT US SOME MORE ON
PROCESS FOR OTHER STAFF AT THE
DJJ I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY-
IS THE YOUTH WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE. STILL ABLE-
THROUGH THE CLOSURE DATE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES. FOR THOSE
SHOES- THAT WE'RE NOT LOSING.
TEACHERS AND- YOU KNOW HEALTH
CARE WORK AND I CORRECTIONAL
THAT THAT WON'T ALLOW DJJ TO
CONTINUE ITS MISSION AND TELL
IT CLOSES WE WILL WE WILL
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO SLOWLY. START
LARA NOW POPULATION DOWN- YOU
MENTIONED- A CALLING ON THE
PLAN YOU MADE I THOUGHT I
THOUGHT WAS A GOOD ONE AND THAT
PLAN IS GOING TO BE FLEXIBLE
BECAUSE WE MAY LOSE STAFF AT A
RATE THAT WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
OR WE MAY NOT AND SO WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ADJUST. AS WE GO- WE HAVE A
RIGHT NOW FOR A DJJ SITES AND-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PRODUCING A
PLAN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND- OUR OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. TO
ENSURE THE SUCCESSFUL GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM KERN HAD A
QUESTION AND SHE SAID SHE
WASN'T GOING TO ASK A QUESTION.
ABOUT THE COVERT I'M NOT ALSO
I'M I SAID THAT WAS MY LAST
QUESTION THAT WILL BE MY LAST
QUESTION BUT I DO JUST WANT TO
LEAVE YOU- SINCE I KNOW THIS
WAS AT A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
AROUND COVE IT AND VACCINATIONS
WERE ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUES.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE- AND UP IN
THE NEWS THIS WEEK AND THE
HEADLINE READS CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS ARE DRIVING THE
PANDEMIC IN PRISON. SO I HOPE
THAT YOU ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO BE
SAFE TO GET VACCINATED IF THEY
CAN- BECAUSE- YOU ARE IN
FACILITIES WHERE THE
VENTILATION IS NOT SO HOT WHERE
THERE STILL IS CONGREGATE CARE-
AND WHERE STAFF ARE AT RISK-
AND SO I JUST HOPE THAT- WE'RE
ABLE TO DO THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO GET IN FRONT OF
THESE KINDS. OF ARTICLES THAT
ARE COMING OUT IN THE NEWS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SO MUCH OTHER
IMPORTANT STUFF TO DO. WE DON'T
WANT THAT PROGRESS TO BE
DERALED BY ADDITIONAL
OUTBREAKS- SO YOU KNOW WHAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR%
TIME AND YOUR SERVICE AND-
TODAY AND RULES I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND- TO ECHO YOU GO IN
LAST LAST- IS- REALLY ALL OF
THOSE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS- THAT
HAVE BEEN ASK I APPRECIATE SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. TODAY AND SO WE WILL
START WITH- ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM-
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE BUT A
REMINDER OF COURSE FOR
WITNESSES I'LL GO AND PUT THIS
UP ON THE SCREEN THAT MAY WISH
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE-
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
EIGHT NINE.AND THAT ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE AND WITH THAT WE
WILL START AGAIN I AS I SAID IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OKAY I THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
WOULD MAKE THE ASSUMPTION
THERE'S PROBABLY NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE BUT I'M LOOKING AT
THE ROOM NOW VIA COMPUTER AND
THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE.
N. OUT WELCOME OUR MODERATOR AS
I DO SO. I WANT TO REMIND
WITNESSES- ODD THAT WE ASK WHEN
YOU SPEAK TO PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR NAME. THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT.
AND OF COURSE AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF OUR COURT REPORTER. IF HE
WOULD SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY
WE WOULD APPRECIATED AND WITH
THAT. WELCOME MODERATOR TH
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE SUPPORT FOR THE NOMINEES
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THOSE INSTRUCTIONS AGAIN ARE
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE HE JUST JUST A MOMENT
PER FIRST COMMENT. AGAIN IF
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE THEIR SUPPORT FROM THE
NOMINEES PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO LOCAL FIRST TIME LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM I'M CLAUDE
BLUESTEIN SPEAKING OF IN
SUPPORT OF MRS JENNIFER
BARRETTO. I'VE BEEN A
CALIFORNIA REGISTERED LOBBYISTS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE WORKING
PRIMARILY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
PUBLIC POLICY FIELDS. I
PERSONALLY KNOWN MRS BARRETTO
OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS THROUGH A
VOLUNTEER YOUTH SPORTS PROGRAMS
SERVING ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YOUTH IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THROUGH MY TIME WITH MRS BREAD-
SHE'S DEMONSTRATED A STRONG
GRASP OF COLLABORATION IN THE
LEADERSHIP SETTING. AND
GENUINELY HAS A SERVANT'S HEART
LAST TO HAVE HER IN OUR BOWLING
PRO THE PEOPLE CAL ARE BLESSED
TO HAVE HER SERVE IN A
LEADERSHIP CAPACITY FOR THE
STATE. I SUPPORTER CONFIRMATION
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE IN A LINE. THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LED MACINNES WE REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF JEFFREY
MCCUMBER AND JENNIFER BARRETTO
AND THEY'VE MAINTAINED AN OPEN
DOOR POLICY FOR ORGANIZATION
AND CONSISTENTLY FALL THROUGH
IN REGARDS TO OUR NEEDS
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC- THEY'VE BEEN THAT
FAIR AND RESPONSIVE TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS. IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
SUPPORT FROM THE NOMINEES IS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TH. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A MOMENT. SO WE WILL NOW I'D
TURNED TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. N. I
WILL AGAIN START RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AND THERE
IS- THERE ARE NONE THERE ARE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IT SEEMS SO
CHECKING OUT ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGAIN AN ART NO ONE THERE SO
MISTER MODERATOR I'M GOING TO
COME BACK TO YOU. ARE FOR
WITNESSES WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THE
NOMINEES ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE YOU
HEAR A TONE AND ALSO BE
PROVIDED YOUR LINE NUMBER BY AN
OPERATOR BEGAN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN THE ZERO. WE HAVE ONE LINE
IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION AND
LOCAL BORDERLINE FIFTEEN YES GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAUREN
ADAMS AND I AM THE LEGAL
DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S LIBERATION
FRONT A PROGRESSIVE FEMINIST
ORGANIZATION FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS PART
OF OUR WORK IS ADVOCACY FOR
SINGLE SEX PREGNANT AND I'M
HERE TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
THANK THE QUICK FACT 82% OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN ARE VICTIMS
OF ABUSE AND THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN OF
COLOR DISPROPORTIONATELY GREW
UP IN POVERTY THEIR DEMAND
AIRCRAFT AND LYFT LIKELY TO BE
VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND ONLY 4%
OF FEMALE INMATES ARE SEX
OFFENDERS. BY CONTRAST 20%
TRANSLATE INTO FIVE MALE
INMATES ARE SEX OFFENDERS
ACCORDING TO UC IRVINE SOME OF
THESE MEN ARE NOT BEING HOUSED
WITH WOMEN UNDER THE
STEWARDSHIP WE ARE IF THE
HANDFUL OF THEM- INCLUDE SEAN
GUSTAFSON ELECTED A SIX YEAR
OLD AN EIGHT YEAR OLD AND HE IS
IN HOUSE IN THE I. W. FULLY
INTACT MALE GENITAL. TAKEN
HUNDRED ONE DEATHSTROKE A
MURDERING JEWS ENGINE HE IS
BEING HOUSED IN THE SAME
FACILITY AT THE VICTIM'S MOTHER
ANTHONY LIPSIUS SERVING FOR
MURDER HERE HIS EMAIL DOMINATE
AND A BRIEF AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING DUMPED A DIFFERENT
WITHOUT QUESTION IT UNDER AND
FOR SOME ASSAULT HIS VICTIM TO
MEDIA TO IT MEMBER TOLD ME THAT
IF SHE WANTED TO BE SEPARATE
FROM HIM SHE WOULD NEED TO GO
TO ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION
JONATHAN ROBERTSON WAS
TRANSFERRED IN JUNE AND IT'S
ALREADY IN ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION PENDING A FACTUAL
ABOUT INVESTIGATION AND PATRICK
WHITE WHO IS A CONVICTED RAPIST
AND A MEMBER OF THE ARYAN
BROTHERHOOD THOSE ARE JUST A
HANDFUL- OF THE W. THE MAN WHO
ARE NOW BEING HOUSED THERE I'M
VERY DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INFORMATION DISCONNECT BETWEEN
CENTRAL CDC ARE AND THE WHEN
THE FELONIES THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF TIMES AND REPENT-
MONTHS WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
UNAWARE OF THINGS GOING ON. AND
JUST IMAGE SHARING MISTER
MCCUMBER SAID THAT BODY CAMERAS
ARE TURNED OFF DURING STRIP
SEARCHES AND THE OFFICE OF THAT
APPROPRIATETO DO SO. BUT
ACTUALLY OFFICIAL POLICY AT W.
THAT OFFICERS MUST KEEP THEIR
BODY CAMS ON DURING STRIP
SEARCHES. AND THE FOOTAGE IS
BEING TAPED IN THE CLOUD OF
COURSE TO ONE CORRECTIONAL THE
IS IN PLACE MALATHI WHO ARE
BEING IN MY INSTANCE ARE GET
ERECTIONS DURING STRIP SEARCHES
AND MAKING TAX COMMON THAT IN
THAT COULD DISCUSS THAT A JULY
INFLATED BY THREE COUNCIL
MEETING. IN THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE WOMEN REGARDING THE
ISSUE MANY OF THESE WOMEN HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSED AND NOW
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO BE STRIP
SEARCHED. VIDEO MAY GET AN
EMAIL THAT THE COURT AGENT
BEING TAPED IN THE CLOUDS. THE
COSBY AND BEER A MOST OF THE
STAFF I HAVE A QUOTE AN INMATE
WHO WANTED TO READ THE SENTENCE
IS THE MOST MALICIOUS WAY TO.
ABUSED WOMAN WHAT WE WENT THERE
WASN'T IMPORTANT. DESPITE OUR
TRAUMA WE ARE FORCED TO LIVE
SHOWER IN COLD PROCESS WITH OUR
PAIN BY BRINGING MEN INTO THE
ONLY WAY OF LIVING SPACE TO BE
ABLE TO REHABILITATE. TELL ME
HOW IS THAT IN ANY WAY. IF NOT.
YOU ARE SACRIFICING OUR SAFETY
JUST TO KEEP US IN MIND QUIET
DR BY THE ACTIONS OF THOSE IN
POWER I HOPE THIS LETTER
REACHES AND HONESTLY CARING
HAND THE PERSON HUNDREDS OF
LETTERS AND MESSAGES FROM WOMEN
WHO ARE ANYTHING ABOUT THE
LACK. THE I. W. CLARK CLARIFIED
AND GREAT THEY ARE HUMILIATED-
REMEMBER OFF THE BENCH THAT THE
SIXTY W. I. I HOUSE THEY
EXPORTED SIXTY ACTUALLY THEY
WERE BUILT BEFORE AND THEY'RE
HOUSING UP TO EIGHT OF THEM IN
THEIR- AND THE ON THE TWENTY-
IN AND WHILE. WE ARE NEED
BREEDERS THE WOMAN CAME SAFETY
PRODUCTS INCLUDING THANK WOMEN
IN THEIR CARE IF YOU SEE MY
DOCTOR ARE BEING CONSULTED ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AT THE
ONE THIRTY CARE WEEK URGING
THEM TO SEEK INPUT WOMEN RIGHTS
ADVOCATE AND I WOULD TO FIND
WOMEN AT EMAIL PEOPLE SO IF YOU
HAVE A WOMEN'S RIGHTS GROUPS
THAT ADVOCATING FOR THE
MARATHONERS. AND THAT'S NOT A
WOMEN'S RIGHTS- BUT I WOULD
URGE A DIVERSITY OF PERSPECTIVE
IN ONE COMMUNICATION I ALSO
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE INSPECT
GENERAL TO INVESTIGATE THE
CONDITIONS IN THE WOMEN'S
FACILITY. THAT ARE RESULTING
UNEXPECTEDLY HOUSING ON THE
BASIS OF GENDER IDENTITY AND IN
PARTICULAR MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND. ARE
MADE THAT. OUR LEADERS ARE
AWARE OF CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND THAT. DATE UNDERSTANDING
ON OUR BEFORE THE PUBLIC. SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND.
TESTIFIED TODAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- MISTER MODERATOR CAN
I ASK IF WE HAVE MORE WITNESSES.
THE REPRODUCTIVE IN ONE ELSE
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. LET ME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- ASSISTANCE TODAY AS
ALWAYS MR MODERATOR. COLLEAGUES
ARE I WILL MAKE- JUST A
REFERRAL- FOR STAFF- THANK YOU-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE FORWARD
APPROPRIATELY PARTICULARLY- I
DID LET THE WITNESS GO ON A
LITTLE LONGER BECAUSE SHE HAD A
NUMBER OF ITEMS OBVIOUSLY THAT
SHE WANTED TO GET ON THE
RECORD. AND I WOULD SUGGEST WE
FORWARD THAT IS PART OF OUR
ONGOING COMMUNICATION WITH CDC
ARE IN TERMS OF THE ADVISORY
BODIES REPRESENTATION AND OTHER
ISSUES SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- GOES THROUGH A PROPER.
CHANNEL OF COMMUNICATION WITH
CDC ARE THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED
AND I SEE MY STAFF NODDING HER
HEAD SO THANK YOU WITH THAT- I
WILL GO TO SENATOR LAYERED ON A
BRIEF COMMENT THEN I HAVE A
MOTION OKAY A. M. THE COMMON IS
THAT WITH- I THINK IT'S TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE TO DO WITH THE
CHAIR JUST DID IT AND ALL OF
THOSE SHOULD BE VETTED BUT I
WANT TO SAY THIS WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION AND THAT'S WHAT I
WAS REFERRING TO IT IN MY
COMMENTS THAT. I WENT THROUGH A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS AND WAS
SATISFIED ISSUE BY ISSUE THAT
THEY WERE ARE ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED BISA THE DEPARTMENT
DID SO I JUST I DIDN'T FEEL
NEED TO RAISE THEM AND GO
THROUGH THEM IN THE COMMENTS
WHICH I SAID EARLIER BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT I
INDICATE THAT THAT THAT THAT
WAS DISCUSSED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW OUR WOULD
MOVE ALL TRY TO. I REMOVED THE
TWO NOMINEES FOR CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SENATOR IF THERE'S-
MANIFIESTO HERE FOR JUST A
FINAL COMMENT BECAUSE THEY DID
BRING IT UP IN MY OF MY
QUESTIONS REGARDING- DO THE
SEPARATION AT THIS POINT IN
TIME AND I UNDERSTAND FROM
THEIR VERY IN DEPTH RESPONSES
TO OUR QUESTIONS. ABOUT JANUARY
IS A IS A DATE CERTAIN THAT A
LOT OF THESE CHANGES ARE GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTED AFTER LOOKING
AT. THE DATA THAT'S THERE AND
OBVIOUSLY ALL THE COMPLAINTS
THAT ARE COMING AND THAT I
WOULD JUST START SAY THAT ON.
THIS IS URGENT OUR AND IT
SHOULD BE DEALT URGENTLY AND
NOT ANOTHER SEVERAL MONTHS
GOING BY SO THAT MORE AND MORE
START TO COME OUT I THINK IF
IT'S A BLACK MARK THAT THE IS.
PROBABLY NOT JUSTIFIED WHEN YOU
SEE- THAT WE HAVE SUCH
COMPETENT PEOPLE BEEN WORKING
IN A LONG TIME BUT IT IS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS IT
IMMEDIATELY I BELIEVE AND I
JUST WANT THAT ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR LET ME ASK IS THERE A
REQUEST TO SEPARATE THESE ARE
OUR OR WE CAN TAKE THEM
TOGETHER OKAY SEEING US SAYING
THAT THE MOTION IS IN ORDER-
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GROWTH NOT VOTING
OF NOT VOTING KAMLAGER I LONGER
I LAYERED HI I FAITH NOT VOTING
FACE NOT VOTING AT I AM VERY
THREE TO ZERO. THAT IS THREE
TWO ZERO YOUR CONFIRMATION WILL
MOVE ONTO THE SENATE FLOOR AND
LET ME- JOIN MY COLLEAGUES EACH
AND EVERYONE WHO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND ALSO LET ME
SAY CONGRATULATIONS ALSO ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT BY THE
GOVERNOR WE WILL MOVE THESE TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU OKAY
ARM THIS CONCLUDES OUR TODAY'S
PUBLIC PORTION OF THE AGENDA SO
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY-
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION ARSENIC COMMITTEE
ON RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO
EXECUTIVE SESSION THANK YOU BYE
BYE.